allez on va continuer avec un nouvel
invité qui accorda bonjour vous êtes
conseiller municipal délégué à la
culture de la ville de plaisir et avec
vous on va prendre le soleil
oui tout à fait enfin le soleil en tout
cas samedi mais il paraît qu'il va faire
très très beau puisque samedi à partir
de 14 heures et jusqu'à minuit dans le
parc du château et en plus c'est gratuit
c'est le festival escales d'ailleurs et
cette année j'ai dit soleil parce que
c'est très s'est orienté sur les
antilles et pourquoi les enfants en fait
alors c'est plus que les antilles ce
sont les dom-tom plus largement et en
arrondi même les îles les petits bouts
de france eire voilà donc pourquoi pas
de nouvelle calédonie est directement
l'océanie aussi bien l'afrique les
caraïbes
voilà ça fait ça rêve tout sur tout le
globe tout simplement parce que chaque
année on change de thème
et puis à ce festival est né à l'origine
de notre maire actuel joséphine coleman
berger qui a souhaité en tant que
l'adjointe à la culture regrouper toutes
les différentes et pillé différents
quartiers de la ville de plaisir dans un
moment festif unique et et comment est
partagée dans notre formidable parc du
château
bien sûr sous le soleil plutôt que
d'assister à des petites initiatives
locales plus modestes et puis patatras
fédératrice alors ça veut dire qu'on
pourra voir quoi ya pas de ce temps là
il ya plein de choses c'est le programme
est il très large effectivement dire
mais en gros pour briller un peu
l'esprit alors en gros on y vient en
famille parce que on y va dans le pôle
jeux pour les petits les tout petits il
ya de la musique il ya de la danse il ya
des arts visuels il ya d une exposition
formidable 6 2 danny rose yes sur ce
qu'elle a pu voir et faire quand elle
était en océanie donc l'idée c'est ma de
flâner comme ça de pôle en pole alors on
a une jolie un joli plan qui nous
indique ce qui se passe à quelle heure
dans quelle partie
et puis bon selon qu'on est avec ses
amis avec sa famille où l'on rencontre
d'autres personnes
on peut comme ça découvrir les arts du
monde et puis
se restaurer parce que il ya aussi bien
sûr un pôle gastronomique pour passer
une excellente journée et le pôle
gastronomique il est aux couleurs aussi
de local bien sûr de la thématique anti
et il est tout à fait et donc ce sont
des associations de la ville de plaisir
qu'ils sont chaque année volontaires
pour venir inventé finalement leurs
spécialités culinaires et qu'ils vont
tenir la plupart des pôles gastronomique
dans des pôles économiques sont tenus
par les associations locales
le reste ce sont des troupes oui alors
en fait c'est mixte puisque les plaisirs
oies se sont appropriés progressivement
ce festival
effectivement on fait appel à des têtes
d'affiché à des professionnels mais on a
aussi à la fois les élèves du
conservatoire qui ont travaillé toute
l'année qui vont pouvoir se produire
et puis on a bien sûr les associations
qui ont préparé des spectacles de
différents types et puis qui vont le
présentez là devant plaisir on se dit
que c est une organisation de fou oui
bah c'est les services municipaux
évidemment question présent pour tous
annoncé une organisation de fourques c1
c'est un grand projet qui fait
travailler bien sûr sous l'égide de la
direction des affaires culturelles
plusieurs services de la ville on y
travaille à peu près 18 mois al avance
donc le programme de l'année prochaine
art bien engage alors un soin alors vers
à tout à l'heure peut-être ah ben ça
c'est vers ça sera vraisemblablement
autour de la méditerranée et
effectivement il ya tous les services la
propreté la logistique qui sont là en
permanence pour veiller à ce que
l'accueil soit le meilleur possible
18 mois de travail c'est quand même
effectivement beaucoup vous l'avez dit
c'est un festival dont le but est
vraiment de rassembler toute la
population que les iroise et qu'au delà
évidemment oui tout à fait alors bien
sûr ça partait au départ des différents
quartiers et des âmes où vous savez
plaisir est une ville quand même assez
est allé avec une cinquantaine d'ethnies
différentes donc c'est aussi
enrichissant de partager tout ça et puis
de fil en aiguille par le biais des
associations et puis la réputation du
festival maintenant qui dépasse
largement notre bassin de vie
effectivement la 10 à 15000 personnes
qui viennent de toute la région
parisienne j'en profite pour dire qu'il
ya des navettes gratuites c'est ce que
j'allais rebondir de 6
j'ai très organisé puisque sous la garde
de plaisir grignon mettez en place des
navettes pour faciliter l'accès à tout
le monde donc l'an passé plus de quinze
mille visiteurs effectivement c'est
qu'il a très recherchées comme festive
oui on a la chance d'avoir tout de suite
mis la barre je dirais d'un certain
niveau qui fait que et puisqu'on à
l'ensemble de la ville qui se mobilisent
d'ailleurs y compris les écoles on a
aussi des projets pédagogiques avec les
écoles et les collèges et le lycée tout
au long de l'année ils préparent selon
la thématique les activités qu'ils vont
pouvoir produire et se représenter comme
ça devant tout le monde
donc globalement c'est cette dimension
et a fait que ben ça lui beaucoup de
succès assez rapidement et vous savez
combien d'artistes seront présents
samedi
moi je boive ou non des centaines
la descente est simple nom de
l'association aussi représenté euros
c'est pareil c'est pareil c'est une
question piège mais ça se compte par
dizaines a cette fois c'était pas
volontaire de ma part et c'est gratuit
en plus oui c'est gratuit en fait c'est
ça représente la volonté forte de
l'équipe municipale de de proposer aux
habitants et quelque chose vraiment
d'intéressant d'un vrai partage une
vraie session extérieur en famille et
surtout une multi multi culturelle mais
aussi multi générationnel l'idée c'est
qu'on n'y avait que le grand papa grand
moment avec les enfants avec les amis
les voisins et qu'on découvre un petit
peu des choses qu'on ne connaît pas par
l'échangé par le côté festif de la
manifestation à strasbourg cette
manifestation la hampe en l'occurrence
est ce qu'il ya des nouveautés par
rapport aux éditions précédentes où l'on
reste sur le programme a directement on
retrouve à peu près toujours ces trois
quatre pôles principaux danse musique
jeux pour les enfants il ya des
déambulations des marionnettes
par contre on travaille avec madame le
maire pour que à partir de l'année
prochaine on est peut-être quelques
nouveautés on n'a pas encore bien
fini ça mais c'est vrai qu'au bout de
onze ans il va falloir vraisemblablement
ouvrir un petit peu la réflexion pour
donner un petit peu de nouveautés
d'accord ok c'est là c'est là ça c'est
la dixième édition la 11e la 11e par
dont c'est la 11e
c'est la onzième édition est
effectivement le fait que justin pendanx
colonna berger qui était la maire
adjointe à la culture soit devenu maire
de plaisir
du coup ça donne un élan supplémentaire
à ce festival puisque c'est oui voilà
c'est sûr que ça lui donne une aura
supplémentaire bon moi je suis flatté
qu'elle m'ait demandé de 30 sa suite
pour développer ce festival
mais on arrive aussi effectivement à
bout de 10 ans à une boucle qui va
falloir certainement réouvrir et
réinventer un petit peu que je voulais
rien nous annoncer en plateau n'ont pas
encore c'est classe moyenne sera sans
aménité autour de la méditerranée voilà
il boit il faut garder un petit peu de
suspense pour avoir envie de me dire
qu'aussi ledit prochaine d'accord en
tout cas on peut déjà à venir 1 samedi à
partir de 14h c'est parc du château
je vais vous donner la météo pour ce
samedi à téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent donc samedi matin c'est très
beau pour la ville de plaisir samedi a
remis un petit peu plus voilé mais
températures sont douces un long nez
ambiance très chaleureuse et donc perdre
à jamais à tout les jours après c'est
sûr avec des antilles et les hits ça
c'est sûr que ce sera très très
chaleureux merci beaucoup fils kordan
être venu sur le plateau 17,8 week end